If you had to buy a new car every time you
had to go somewhere, you'd be broke by Tuesday.
So, why not apply the same logic to space
travel.
90s kids will remember the space shuttle launches
that ferried astronauts and cargo to the ISS.
But even the reusable shuttle was expensive,
and so the program ended in 2011.
According to the founder of SpaceX, Elon Musk,
the shuttle was too complex, and money could
be saved if the rocket was simplified.
Simplifying a rocket.
How hard could that be?
Well, after few crash landings and explosions,
SpaceX seems to have the self-landing reusable
rocket thing figured out.
So, does this make space travel cheaper?
Space shuttle missions cost about 450 million
dollars per launch, and while that sounds
like a lot more than SpaceX’s price of $133
million, you have to remember the Space Shuttle
was a beast of a craft, capable of carrying
50,000 pounds of cargo AND 7 crew members.
Broken down by the pound Shuttle flights cost
about 10,000 dollars whereas a SpaceX Dragon
stuffed to the gills costs 9,100 dollars for
every pound of cargo.
That’s well shy of Musk’s ultimate goal
of bringing down the cost of space travel
by a at least a factor of 10.
But, he hopes to hit those numbers by launching
more cargo at once on their next rocket, the
Falcon Heavy.
For now SpaceX has started launching reused
Falcon-9 rockets and says the cost of refurbishing
one is less than half of building one from
scratch.
They still have to recoup their investment,
but eventually Musk says prices will drop.
The thing is, SpaceX is competing for government
contracts with another company called United
Launch Alliance or ULA, a joint venture of
Lockheed-Martin and Boeing.
Based on the US Air Force’s 2018 budget
estimate, it looks like ULA will charge 422
million dollars per launch in 2020.
SpaceX, on the other hand, has done similar
jobs for only 83 million dollars.
So things are allegedly cheaper.
Though, how much of that 300 million dollars
difference is down to the rocket, is up for
debate.
In fact, the Government Accountability Office
has criticized ULA for a lack of transparency
on pricing.
While some would argue ULA charges that much
because they’re up against the margin and
can’t cut costs, Musk thinks they charge
that much because they can.
They used to have no competition, their launch
record is outstanding, and the satellites
they’re launching cost billions, so what’s
a few hundred million dollars between friends?
While the Department of Defense can accept
the higher launch costs because their budget
is bigger than God’s, NASA is, by comparison,
a poor pauper that has to make a lump of coal
last the winter.
In 2015 NASA received 34 times less money
than the DOD.
So, if SpaceX can save NASA money, it would
be an ideal partnership.
The next thing NASA needs is a way to transport
people.
SpaceX’s unfinished Dragon 2 spacecraft
is designed to carry people at a price of
58 million dollars per seat.
Pretty good considering the only other ride
to the ISS is aboard a Russian Soyuz, and
since the shuttle’s retirement they’ve
been hiking the price.
They’re planning to charge 81 million dollars
a seat next year.
I for one hope he does manage to get that
price down, because I don’t think I can
save up 58 million dollars before I die.
Maybe I should invent some sort of service.
Like an easy way to pay my pals or something.
I don’t know, get back to me on this one,
Elon.
Thanks for watching, if you like what you
see may I casually direct you to the subscribe
button.
If you bought a ticket to space, how high
would you have to go before you technically
got there?
Trace tells you where space starts here.
So would you hitch a ride on a rocket if you
could?
Let us know in the comments, and thanks for
watching